hey guys i'm ryan right so we're gonna
check out from Conan Sir Patrick Stewart
loves a male kiss nan on man action here
we go
I saw a photo not long ago when I and I
thought we should talk about it because
it's a it's a fantastic image it is you
with Sir Ian McKellen and you're you
know an Xavier I think this is when you
first met know your old friends your old
friends you've known each other a long
time and you you guys went in for a kiss
on the lips in front of all the press on
a red carpet on a red that's on a red
carpet yeah I knew what I was doing it
took him by surprise
Sir Ian a little by surprise there was
the it was the world premiere of his
movie mr. Holmes which is wonderful
yes yeah Oscar nomination yes yes and
well we are very good friends and quite
intimate friends can I use that word on
this room how dare you word intimate
know your old friends but that's that's
quite you initiated this this this this
kiss I did yeah because it seemed
appropriate and that is how we greet one
another or say goodbye but Ian isn't the
only one I don't want you to think I am
a one-man guy no or you can only kiss
other sirs yeah
it's the only nights that can kiss you
baby see Ben Kingsley are you guys
making out yeah I think who would I go
for if I I think I think I'd go for sus
Sean ohh Sean Connery yeah yeah
all right maybe a bit of tongue you say
this is quite this is this is something
you do this is something that you're
comfortable doing entirely yeah oh yes
yeah but I don't do it with strangers
you want to try it I was not going for
that you were looking at me in a way
that my record
does this look appetizing to you right
now
so please Wow
that was fantastic
you're incredible
I felt passion yeah you you went right I
mean you're iconic actor you're a great
man and you in we kissed and I just I
felt that you suddenly accepted me as
your better did you feel he is important
did you feel a connection and I'm not
just talking about a physical did you
feel an emotional why is it unacceptable
for a heterosexual men to kiss each
other on who says it's unacceptable I
say it should be a commonplace if you
say it it will happen
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos oh man
Patrick Stewart man he's [ __ ]
hilarious he's such a great dramatic
actor he's a fantastic traumatic actor I
remember the first time I heard him do
comedy was like American Dad and like
his narration in Ted or playing himself
on Family Guy he's he's great with
comedy and I remember his been an extra
yeah and he hasn't you shell out I
forgot it's called but I think it's a
comedy and I want to watch it no I don't
watch it in Conan if you're watching I
want to be on your show
I would totally I wouldn't stick my
tongue out I just and he would suck my
tongue can you imagine an orgy with you
Conan me and Fallon like just the four
of us just all boning each other that
would be hot older and which I'm not but
wow you gave a really genuine answer yes
I gotta get a little better you guys are
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can check out the
salamander Sally's Channel fun [ __ ] on
there with hot blonde friend yeah it's
pretty hot yeah and you could follow us
on Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope and you shut up
Brandon Jarvis hi real rejects still
can't spell real the correctly would
really love a shout-out you guys make me
laugh when I'm down from Brian's weird
masturbation jokes - Gerry you mean
awkward about Ryan jokes the girls are
sweet and sexy Ryan you have a good
girlfriend never forget that but I hope
to see more videos from you guys cuz
you're just that funny to watch well
tell you what Brandon Jarvis right now
I'm gonna make my last masturbation joke
on this channel just for you kidding i
secrete come at a moment's notice it's
not a sexual thing it's a power Thank
You Brandon for helping me come up with
that joke you're an awesome you mean